[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale du 7-8 loisirs vous l'aurez
compris une édition spéciale consacrée à
halloween malgré l'actualité morose
nous allons essayer de vous redonner le
sourire tout de suite le sommaire samedi
31 octobre c'est halloween cette année
sera un peu particulière puisque la fête
se fera à la maison confirmant oblige
nous vous donnerons des idées pour des
activités à faire chez vous plutôt
horreur ou comédie quels sont les films
à voir pour halloween
notre chroniqueuse mélanie qui nous
donnera ses trois coups de coeur et peut
enfin aller bonbons ont-ils toujours la
cote
réponse à la fin de cette édition dans
un magasin spécialisé
c'est un nouveau confinement qui
débutera ce jeudi dans quelques heures
maintenant pour au moins un mois
un coup dur pour le secteur des loisirs
beaucoup avaient prévu des activités à
l'extérieur
alors comment fêter halloween tout de
même mélanie poker est allé demander des
conseils aux saint quentinois qu'on a
décoré la maison on achetait bonbons
mais on va rester à la maison
après on peut toujours en confinement
ont regardé un film faire un repas
faire un repas avec de la citrouille
j'étais censée fêter halloween avec des
amis donc on était une dizaine à peu
près donc on devait se déguiser tout ça
dans un appartement parisien donc c'est
très chouette mais du coup avec le
confinement va tout est annulé
j'en suis dégoûté quoi je vais rien
faire du tout je vais rentrer chez mes
parents à qui on va faire des gâteaux
on a acheté des bonbons un petit film
est petit est un enjeu de société un
petit escape game et on a des jeux
maison un escabeau pourquoi faire ça et
nous aussi nous allons vous donner trois
activités à la maison à faire et
pourquoi pas commencer par une chasse
aux bonbons comme la chasse aux oeufs
pour pas que vos enfants apprécieront de
rechercher les friandises caché dans
toute la maison
soyez imaginatifs pour les cachettes
comme la salle de bains les pots de
fleurs ou encore derrière les étagères
ou les livres et si vous avez une petite
faim je vous conseille les droits de
sortie hier ce sont des doigts défaut
doit couper servi en amuse gueule sale
et il vous faut des saucisses de
strasbourg une pâte feuilletée des
amandes entières et du ketchup
la recette des coupes et des saucisses
de strasbourg en deux puis découper des
rectangles des rectangles de la longueur
des saucisses enroulée chaque tronçon
deux sociétés dans la pâte feuilletée
fermer le bout rond de la saucisse et
placer une demie à mende du côté fermé
mettre au four 20 à 25 minutes est
présenté sur une assiette avec des
taches de ketchup et le tour est joué et
enfants qu'est ce que serait halloween
sans citrouille pour le matériel c'est
très simple il vous faut un couteau une
cuillère à soupe un feutre et une bougie
ensuite vous retirerez toute la chair à
la cuillère dessiner un visage
terrifiant et le découper puis placez la
bougie pour une décoration halloween
réussi
[Musique]
halloween à la maison c'est aussi
l'occasion de passer une soirée
cocooning devant la télé mélanie poké
bonsoir enfin vous avez sélectionné
quelques idées de films plus ou moins
effrayant et oui des films pour ce
format où il y en a bon nombre il ya
massacre à la tronçonneuse l'exorciste
hérédité shine ou encore ce film culte
avec un titre tout trouvé halloween
réalisé par john carpenter l'histoire de
michael myers un jeune homme qui
s'échappe d'un asile psychiatrique et
qui s'en prend aux adolescents de la
ville
[Musique]
mais si on est facilement effrayé pour
halloween
on peut aussi regarder des films drôles
et oui les froussards comme moi peuvent
aussi passer une soirée halloween est ce
qu'avec son bilan de sortie en 2009 fait
place au second degré dans un monde
plein de zombies woody harrelson jesse
eisenberg emma stone et abigail breslin
tentent de survivre ou encore shaun of
the dead là aussi des zombies là aussi
de la survie et surtout de sacrés fous
rires jaunes et aides sont deux amies
qui se retrouvent dans une banlieue de
londres totalement insisté
[Musique]
c'est mal frappé les à la tête des
salaires de mars 8
pourquoi les chais liste parce que je
laime d'accord ferry
ne bougeait plus et alors si on veut
plutôt profiter d'une soirée en famille
on sait comment ça commence on va voir
aussi il ya beaucoup de films ce que les
plus jeunes ils ont aussi le droit de se
faire peur ou du monde de frissonner qui
n'a pas enfants eu quelques sursauts
avec les gremlins casper la famille
adams ou encore les noces funèbres
plus récemment il y a eu au tel
transylvanie c'est l'histoire de l'eau
thème du comte dracula ou les monstres
et leurs familles peuvent vivre sans
leur vie sans être ennuyés par les
humains jusqu'à ce que l'on de l'un
d'entre eux débarquent
[Musique]
je faisais de l'escaladé avec quelques
potes et j'ai entendu parler d'un
château mortels d'ailleurs au plan de
mortels je capte jure j'ai une pilule
la soirée peut même me permettre de voir
les suites deux autres volets sont
sortis en 2015 et en 2018 merci mélanie
pour ces quelques idées une liste bien
sûr non exhaustive et mélanie j'ai une
petite question pour vous est ce que
vous aimez les bonbons aux enfants
raffolent j'en raffole vaut mieux parler
c'est très bon pour moi eh ben c'est
très bien fait et menaces qu'on va
parler de ces petites friandises que
l'on peut consommer à tout âge cette
année difficile d'aller à la chasse aux
bonbons et et de frapper aux portes des
voisins mais les bonbons ne peuvent très
bien se consommer à la maison les
magasins spécialisés font carton plein
un montage de romain respire dans cette
boutique de bonbons situé dans le centre
commercial sqy ouest à montigny le
bretonneux des centaines de kilos de
friandises sont vendus chaque jour en
cette période d'halloween c'est je pense
fondamental dans cette fête il ya l'idée
de se faire plaisir et l idée d'offrir
de donner de donner gratuitement
généreusement si j'ose dire
halloween est l'emblème le symbole c'est
effectivement la confiserie pour les
enfants selon les enfants cette année
sera particulière pour fêter halloween
on pas faire la chasse canton
pourquoi dans
parce qu'il ya le virus tu as parfois
d'autres à la place là je vais faire un
ropa d'aller y est con et les
confiseries seront bien sûr sur toutes
les tables le magasin une centaine de
références spécialement pour halloween
serpent vert souris ou encore tête de
mort vous pouvez même piéger vos
convives avec des bonbons cerise au
piment
ah oui alors un goût de la cerise moi
j'adore la cerise et le piment derrière
qui arrive c'est très fort mais c'est
bon moi j'aime bien pimentée c'est
surprenant même franchement c'est
qu'après je mange un bonbons piments et
le best-seller de cette année les yeux
trop me c'est un bonbon rond gélatineux
en forme de pupille forme d'oeil et
quand vous le croquer à l'intérieur il
ya une un coulis acide qui se répondent
dans votre bouche qui donne l'impression
de croquer un oeil un véritable et s'est
il fait un carton
halloween est la deuxième période la
plus importante de l'année après noël
pour ce magasin qui dit halloween dit
déguisements sorcières vampires ou
encore au cloud reste les
incontournables pour effrayer vos
parents ou vos enfants
notre journaliste justin brasier est
allé dans l'un des plus grands magasins
du département où il existe plus de
vingt mille références dont plus de 3000
juste pour halloween
regardez
halloween approche à grands pas et pour
l'occasion nous sommes actuellement à
l'intérieur d'un des plus grands
magasins à deux fêtes de la région
nous allons voir comment les yvelinois
se séparent pour cette fête à la maison
cette année en compagnie de catherine
bonjour bienvenue chez fait sensation
merci vous êtes la gérante du magasin
exactement avec mon mari damien est ce
que pourrait nous expliquer un peu le
bilan est ce que on décore toujours
notre maison est ce qu'on voulait guise
toujours pour halloween est alors il
reste une fête très populaire et très en
vogue
tout le monde joue le jeu peut-être
toutes générations confondues petit
grand adolescent personnes âgées
tout le monde aime jouer le jeu d'année
est ce que vous seriez vous dire un peu
comment les yvelinois se prépare on
s'organise pour cette fête d'halloween
alors cette année c'est un petit peu
exceptionnel vu la conjoncture actuelle
toutes les familles sont déjà à préparer
à fêter halloween à la maison donc ça se
passe en petit comité de la décoration
bien évidemment des jeu du déguisement
et puis surtout de la créativité dans
les maquillages et si vous avez des
exclusivités notamment un bar à ballon
et un bar à masquer exactement est-ce
qu'on peut aller voir ça bien sûr albert
on y va
[Musique]
on se trouve devant le bar à masquer une
exclusivité à ici dans le magasin est ce
que quelqu'un vous pouvez nous expliquer
un peu le concept alors le concept du
bar and haas que c'est bien sûr
l'exposition de ce grand mur avec une
multitude de masques de tout choix que
ce soit les animaux et puis bien sûr les
incontournables les clowns tout ce qui
est dément personnage horrible katrina
par les masques quels sont les
accessoires tendances pour halloween
alors notre clientèle chez fait
sensation aime beaucoup tout ce qui est
transfert fausse cicatrice est également
les lentilles reste les accessoires
incontournables dans une tenue digne
d'halloween et en parlant d'
incontournable ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on aille voir un peu les
déguisements incontournable avec les
airs ce week-end j'en suis
nous voici dans le rayon des
déguisements donc ici à partir de cet
endroit là jusque ici nous avons plus
les déguisements dédié à la fête
d'halloween d'accord rangés par thème
par rayon enfant adulte alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut trouver qui revient un peu
chaque année alors ce qui revient chaque
année bien évidemment dont les enfants
ce sera les sorcières les ventes ur des
petites choses toutes mignonnes quad la
citrouille et en grandissant on prend
plaisir à faire peur donc on va aimer
les méchantes fait les sorcières mais
aussi les comptes est diabolique
les vampires et puis vampiresse et pour
les adultes catherine qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve alors j'ai fait sensation vient
surtout chercher des déguisements
d'horreur le client adore tout ce qui
est vêtements ensanglantés
mais également comme pour les enfants
les sorcières les clowns on retrouve
également tout ce qui est jean bie et
puis les clean bien évidemment
terrifiant or il toujours pour faire
peur
exactement est-ce que vous avez une
tenue à me conseiller écouté volontiers
je vous sélectionnerez bien le costume
d'arles est clean personnages partent
pour cette année si vous avez les
saignées je vais l'essayer
merci beaucoup 4 à leur nom merci d'être
venus si réd sansfaçon merci et moi je
vais l'essayer mon costume
bon bah voilà moi je suis prêt de
j'espère que vous l'êtes aussi y'a plus
qu'à décorer la maison et puis à vous
déguiser le jour j et c'est la fin de ce
set it was here spécial halloween
merci de nous avoir suivis bonne soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on